sollers et ses frères et tu le vois des
liens déjà il ouvre la bouche tu sais
que tu vas galerie c'est un truc dont
les plus grands vins de bouder en plus
aussi j'ai une surprise non plus pour
toi pour si je le dis il ya de plus en
plus de fans de goodyear qui rentrait
vraiment de d'explosives la jolie c'est
vrai et ça me fait tellement plaisir
mais bon oui c'est vrai alors comme
chaque jeudi vous savez que je
récompense le meilleur et le pire de
tout cas on peut se dire sur ça et c'est
tous les jeudis et parmi vous invitez
préféré cyril la question clavier ah
ouais ya deux jours il ya bouder et ya
aussi les frères bogdanov i bogdanov
il est plus que mes fans des films
viennent plus souvent dans les missions
que christophe carrière
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non pas du tout il l alpe d'huez on
l'embrassé
alors les femmes boudanov on les adore
parce que quand ils viennent on apprend
des choses et en plus ils savent qu'ils
vont se faire vanner mais ça fait
toujours rire il adore alors avant de
connaître de tarbes à tout à l'heure
dans quelques instants je voudrais vous
désigner le gagnant du grand tarbes da
tarde bogdan vous allez voir qui c'est
pas moi
cyril hanouna qui est obligé de baisser
les yeux parce qu'il n'assume pas trop
savane un détecteur de menton jean
michel mr fayoux avec cyril hanouna mais
pas avec les bogdanoff
ça fait combien d'années ce n'est pas
dans mes écouteurs
comment cet enjeu à l'assemblée il faut
dormait pas du tout non un peuple entre
une heure et deux heures par nuit sans
s'asseoir et cyril hanouna qui veut
absolument placer savane
alors il pose la même question 50 fois
pour pouvoir la glisse et vous habitent
ensemble
non je veux non non chacun chez vous et
chacun chez soi chacun chez soi des vous
tombez mais en définitive il ya quelque
chose de plus
quoi que vous habitiez ensemble moi
n'ont semblé longtemps habitués sur le
moment oui mais en fait bon cessé
quelques semaines le dire écoutez vous
avez dit chacun chez soi et les mentons
seront bien gardées populaire mais merde
c'est pas la ceiba j'étais pas là tu
vois bien qu'ils ont pas changé en temps
je perds m'avoir garde champêtre alors
qui est pour vous jean-mi parce que
c'est vraiment mes choix c'était honnête
ça fait combien d'années je n'ai pas
donc écoute sur comment c'est un jeu non
sans rigoler photo remet pas du tout non
d'or un peuple entre une heure et deux
heures par nuit sans rigoler ça se voit
tout le monde
[Rires]
j'adore parce qu'on les adore mais ça
sortait du coeur super sympa mais je me
dis parce que je sais qu'il a bien sûr
vieux cd amour variations dans leur big
bang
tout ça alors vous savez que quand un
imitateur imite une personnalité c'est
que cette personnalité c'est une star
oui c'est pour ça que personne n'imite
matthieu delormeau aussi sympa comme
celui là c'est pas vrai ordi limite moi
et je suis météo d être réalisés c'est
pas vrai oui alors vous série ça
n'arrête pas dans toutes vos émissions
vous imitent notamment dans la première
de la grosse rigolade qu'on a tous
fraudeurs dont elle a deux côtés très
bon il ya une grosse concurrence avec
une personne qui se trouve ici qui vous
est même très bien alors pour la
meilleure imitation de cyril hanouna
les nommés sont chantal ladesou dans la
grosse rigolade
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
valérie bénaïm dans touche pas à mon
poste dit la vérité la vérité
non mais c'est de la merde oui et
philippe lachaux dans la grosse rigolade
[Rires]
elles se gardent de suite
[Applaudissements]
y'a pas et a pas de débat cet outil
exceptionnel parce qu'il s'est même ma
tête quand je vais la jambe filfila
chaud que j'embrasse fort lutrin à
mourenx 30 exceptionnel et merci mon
fils qui est très très fort et c'est de
l'impro et là c'est comme ça qu il
n'avait pas préparé il avait un peu peur
et finike exceptionnelle la gagne alors
chaque semaine je vous propose d'élire
la meilleure vannes qu'on a entendues
dans l'émission alors qu'il est le digne
successeur de laurent baffie à les
nommer son jean michel lemaire qui fait
ce qu'on a fait tout à l'heure l'hôtesse
est comme quand tu demandes à une meuf
tu viens de la pécho tu demande d'actifs
et vous demandez vous baigner le voilà
non bah jean michel rousseaux pas moi je
ne manque jamais quand vous applaudir
matthieu delormeau la péter les plombs
il a pété les plombs il a pété les
plombs et quelle est la question
qu'est-il arrivé à claude françois c'est
pas possible c'est talbot et cyril
hanouna mais nettement r oui mais à tête
en arrière
pas mal et il est fort un cast a haussé
à gaubert qui les suit la date is all 6
janvier
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi ce n'était pas une bonne c'est vrai
que de bons amis au tour de france jean
louis mathieu pas mal de france aux tirs
allez allez jeu on le donne à son groupe
de nageurs je prends quelques notes
je vais prendre quelques nuits alors
alors on touche pas à mon poste et une
sur les émissions en direct donc
forcément il ya des séquences soukouna
est normalement au montage et les choses
qu on couperait maintenant ma le monde
est passé montage notamment les rails
ici en vis-à-vis
là on est plein c'est ça et cette
personne reste est d'accord très bien
bonnes femmes tiens je vais en parler
dans un instant assez vraie merde là
qu'il m'a pas que des bonnes nouvelles
j'ai pas que des bonnes non c'est pas la
femme de beinheim donc c'est votre femme
et ma femme en général donc on coupe ce
qui nous arrange pas
notamment les réactions à des choses
inattendues et comme ici sur trois
heures d'émission est quasiment trois
heures de choses inattendues
c'est un festival de réaction alors que
ceux des réactions surpris des réactions
choquées ou bien des noms réaction comme
un célèbre duo représentant d'honneur de
la ville de menton pour la meilleure
réaction les nommés sont
chantal lauby quand on fabien lecoeuvre
lui rappelle une anecdote dont lui seul
a le secret ja
il ya jane il ya fixé sa direction ah
c'est beau c'est très bon oui fabien
lequel a dû succéder à daniel gilbert
parce qu'elle veut nos sites de
franchement ouvert non ça c'est avant
d'en succéder et après la chaux gauche
et un orc et là il est allé de nos
requêtes web est devenu très connu des
défaites 17
[Musique]
cyril hanouna qui n'arrive toujours pas
à s'habituer au fait que bernard montiel
deviennent complètement ouf mais qu'il
est chez nous je vous dis je ne suis pas
du tout ecclésiale et je ne les ai
jamais vu de ma vie
rien qu'à elle elle s'est passé les
pénétrations et igor et grichka
bogdanoff
quand ils entendent cyril hanouna tenir
une grossièreté en radio frère tu auras
toujours un mec à te dire on est premier
sur les mecs qui manque des salsifis un
petit cadeau pour bouder la 25e tarbes
ayora le 25 à rabat que vous attendez et
j'ai des choses à vous dire sur votre
femme f e
[Rires]
je savais qu'à chaque fois que je fais
en quête de baba jan rend toujours
hommage à un certain mohamed benyamna
couderc qui est là et ce soir il a une
surprise parce que tout à l'heure on a
vu le top 5 de tes meilleurs
déguisements sur le plateau avec nous
jean début de saison tu faisais des
bandes annonces
voilà donc lier il a envie de leur faire
bouddha wes découvre aussi tiens on peut
lancer un truc sur twitter soit c'est
vrai qu'on refasse exactement il a
raison voilà on voit sur twitter ce que
vous voulez qu'on refasse les
bandes-annonces de bouder oui 36 15
codes ben oui ou non à les hisser les
bandes annonces et vous allez voir vous
allez élire le meilleur déguisement de
bouder sur ces bandes annonces dans
nador on adore et oui ou mourir bouder
s'habille en prada tout le monde
attachez vos ceintures
miranda priestly c'est la rédactrice en
chef
quand vous parlez de moi c'est une
méchante vivant je m'appelle ndi
bouder dans la grande muraille
qu'est ce que c'est j'attaque plus je
veux combattre à vos côtés je souhaite
bonne chance à moins que vous n'ayez pas
moins peur
et booder ans carole rousseau enquête
sous tension présenté par carole
rousseau
bové ce sont ces supputations gens me
suivent
[Applaudissements]
car en lançant cette magie magie avant
moi je moi je mets le diable s'habille
en prada s'est d'abord on a peur bravo
vous avez tout vas toi frère moi si
gentil et suicidaire je remercie toutes
les équipes
ah bah oui mais la siv avec moi olivier
olivia bits tout ça et ça vote là sur
twitter à savon crois que c'est eux qui
votent sur toi vote avait été déjà un
crédit à payer bah moi je suis pour tout
cas moi je dis moi je dis je suis pour
voici à quoi il est temps d'en venir aux
moments dont tout le monde parle chaque
matin à la machine à café qui est le
plus attaqué ses collègues cette semaine
en touche pas à mon poste qui est le
tard baba musique de suspense qui sera
le 25e tabac
qu'est ce qu'une enfin détrôner l'animal
qui s'agrippe à son trophée tanoh
chihuahua à sa croquette le 25e tabac et
contre toute attente c'est bien c'était
vraiment là valérie benaïm qui était là
elle s'affirmait la réponse à l'attaqué
alors vous allez voir qu'on attaque fort
avec intro à la suite après 1,3 la suite
c'est quoi c'est qu'il ya trois
chroniqueurs comprennent pas la gueule
en cavale après un strike fait commencé
deux heures de sport par semaine
j'essaie au moins de faire deux trois
fois par semaine une heure une heure et
demie cfoot inquiet j'ai eu une fois
tous les dix ou même façon trop belle
exactement les deux n'ont pas besoin
c'est fou rire là du moins de boulot
focus list et l'année prochaine nous en
aurait moins 90% des gens qui change de
coiffure feu sur les gardes elle n a pas
changé depuis 18 jours d'août j'ai cru
qu'on était dans ça commence aujourd'hui
faustine bollaert
oui bah je sais pas vous allez y allez
bientôt on va commencer aujourd'hui ça
va se finir 2
et on va se retrouver aussi dans un
instant avec le pourquoi de baba et bien
sûr il y aura le scoop de maxime guennic
à du gros scoop aujourd'hui est vrai je
déconnais mathieu toi tu es plutôt je
suis un leader et ce leader dans la vie
je suis leader à l'antenne je suis un
leader au leader leader price
[Applaudissements]
c'est parce que je vous aime voilà c'est
l'âme humaine
cédric tu es de retour la vie mon chéri
tu m'as dit il
[Applaudissements]